misinformation in the united states is
eroding our information environment it's
polarizing society
uh it's hurting uh and
it's hurting a lot of different
dimensions um but in places like african
countries and southeast asia
misinformation is killing people
hello and welcome to women's balls where
i categorize speech today's trail places
bournemouth my guest today graduated
with a degree in electrical and computer
engineering in the franklin w olin
college of engineering
she went on to work for some of the most
famous tech giants in the world
including google yelp pinterest and
facebook
whilst there she became shocked that the
company seemed to in her own words harm
children's stoke division and weak in
our democracy
leaving the company in 2021 she became
one of the most famous whistleblowers
leading to the wall street journal's
expose the facebook files she has
testified both in the u.s and uk about
the harm she believes facebook does to
society and continues to be a vocal
advocate in holding big tech to account
all while the uk government's online
safety bill progresses through
parliament
my guest today is francis haugen
so francis thank you very much for
coming into the office today on this
very very hot day with as you pointed
out a lack of air conditioning um on
this podcast we always begin by asking
would you describe yours as a happy
childhood
so i grew up in iowa city iowa which is
one of these places that's that's um
like a a town out of place so my parents
are from the coasts my mother grew up in
new york i'm outside of new york city my
father's from berkeley california
and they met in the middle in iowa
because that's where the university of
iowa was
and iowa city is an amazing place to be
um
uh you know the child of two academics
because you have amazing freedom like i
my parents literally gave me a bus pass
and let me wander around during the
summer when i was seven and you can do
that safely because you know there's a
hundred thousand people there's a
hundred thousand people in town when
school's in session there's like maybe
25 or 30 000 people in town when the
school's not in session
um and so i i had they have amazing
schools there's a remarkable number of
early facebook employees that were my
classmates in my high school in iowa um
and i'm very grateful for the experience
experiences i got to have there
now your mother is a priest so his
religion isn't a big part of your
upbringing you know it's interesting so
my mother became a priest when i was in
college and um so she was a life
scientist she's a cell biologist a
professor for 20 or 25 years and in her
50s she became a priest
and um uh and so religion was not like a
huge part of my childhood it was a thing
that my mother really got into um when i
was in high school and then later on in
college what were you were you already
thinking about a career in tech or no i
don't think i ever intended to have a
career in tech um i
originally
um all i knew was i wanted to
be able to so one of the downsides of
living in an academic town
is that the
you don't have a lot of past like what
does it look like to be an adult because
a disproportionate share of the adults
that you interact with are either like
teachers in public schools which are
which is a great and very valuable
career path where they're professors and
often they have like ivy league degrees
so there's this like very weird
dichotomy of like you know are you are
you going to like go to a good school
and you can have a job that supports
yourself or are you going to
um be a service worker right it's it's
not a diversified economy um and so i
my friends and i we all had this very
very strong desire to do well enough in
school that we could we could we could
get into good schools um and you know i
know there's lots of happy paths to
staying in iowa but it was one of those
things where i was exposed to
a very
shallow set of experiences and so that's
part of why i was so academically
ambitious
and now you're going to study electrical
and computer engineering
and i just wanted i guess for listeners
i mean i it's almost a
i can't quite remember when i grew up
with facebook i think there was bibo for
a while
or something so so when you went to go
and study this what did the
it feels now so it's quite obvious that
there's you know big tech and it's a
huge huge industry what did it look like
back then oh interesting so when i was
in college um so uh most people aren't
aware so facebook was founded in 2004.
the big social network in 2004 was
actually friendster so that was like
probably the largest one in the world um
and the only reason why today we don't
know of fronster is friendster didn't
wasn't good enough at building the
actual technical engineering right that
uh the math behind social networks is
very very expensive for computers and
friendster grew so fast in popularity
that the site became unusable
and um the first there are these
programs called crawlers and crawlers uh
their computer programs that walk across
the web you know the world wide web
and download content and the first
crawler i ever wrote i wrote actually
when i studied abroad in sweden in 2004
and it wasn't a facebook it was a
friendster because fronster was the cool
thing then and then the mid-2000s like
maybe 2006 um the big the big social
network was it was myspace
um and so the thing that facebook really
displaced was was not friendster because
friendster kind of killed itself but it
displaced myspace
and uh when you start to when you're
doing your degree um how did you find uh
studying was it male dominated in your
class it was a pretty good mix so i i
went to a very
unique engineering experience which was
um i went to a brand new engineering
college and so there were only 75
students in my entire college when i was
a freshman and because there were so few
students whether we all had full tuition
scholarships
because there were so few students they
could be very picky and they
intentionally had a 50 50 male female
balance because they had lots of strong
female candidates and there were like
very few slots
and so olin is one is the only
engineering school the only engineering
school in the united states that has
more women than olin is smith which is a
women's school a women's college
um and so uh it's interesting i didn't
really experience like large amounts of
sexism in tech until i got to google
and so it was actually a very rude awake
awakening for me to show by google and i
think google at the time was 12 or 13
women on the technical side and so it's
like i've been in this environment where
it's always been you know 50 50 and
wellesley which is a women's college is
five minutes away so i took uh one
eighth of my classes in college at
wellesley
and um to move into an environment where
there are almost no women and so it's
just a very
i don't know unexpected thing and that i
mentioned instruction you just mentioned
of course google some of the places you
work before facebook so yeah pinterest i
wanted so on on graduating what was your
kind of weigh-in
job great great question so i had a very
interesting uh like
job search in that um when i graduated
from college my degree was unaccredited
because i was part of the first
graduating class of my college
and um i originally intended to either
get into grad school or i was going to
go like move on with my parents and do a
startup like basically build a website
or something
and so i applied to 55 jobs and i got
three
i got three phone screens
and i got two in-person interviews and i
got one job offer which is from google
and um
i think the key thing i did not
understand was that uh the only places
basically that i got to interview were
places that act where someone inside the
company endorsed me or where or where
harvard's admission team like they told
boston consulting group they're like you
should interview her
um and so uh
i yeah i ended up at google very
randomly like i never expected to move
to california like i had always been
raised with a father that had left
california so he had a lot of very
critical opinions about california was
he i'm impressed by a plan to go to
california
he was not super pleased but it was the
only job offer i got and like google
google is a great place to start your
career even then yeah what was it like
being in such like a
iconic but also you know very large
organization so early on did you feel
like a little bit like a small cog in a
very big machine i really liked google
like um
uh something that that
may not be obvious is that that um
highly performant startups like really
highly performance arts and i think
google did a great job at this early on
um google felt like a very safe place
where it was a thing where like people
um felt very secure about themselves and
so that it was very collaborative
um and i loved being surrounded by you
know
just masters at their craft and getting
to learn from that and so i loved being
at google
and i want to also talk about you into
facebook but i wonder first maybe just
for our listeners i mean
my husband is a coder and i couldn't
actually tell you what he does every day
um so perhaps you could just explain to
listeners when you're doing your job at
google for example what is a day in the
life in terms of building
so i did a couple different areas at
google so i was a product manager so
product managers um so facebook is a
product and so instagram is a product um
but even within say instagram the box
where you create a new post that itself
is a product and even like the picker
where you say like this person i'm with
this person that's a product an even
smaller product
and i started out at google working on
um
reporting for ads on adwords
and then uh very soon after that started
my second year so i was there for about
seven and a half years i started working
on search quality
so search quality as a product is really
different than what most product
managers do because most product
managers you know if you ask them what
did you contribute to this product they
can point at the button or at the screen
that they were responsible for adding to
that product
but when you work on search quality you
a huge amount of your job is um pulling
out of the databases a bunch of things
that people search for
and seeing what they clicked on or
seeing what does google return for these
results or what results do they return
for the search query
and um and just seeing if you see trends
like oh interesting like there's not
enough diversity in the results on this
page or in my diversity i mean are we
returning the exact same web page over
and over again or
is there a better result that we're not
returning you know in going and trying
some other strategies for trying to
retrieve that information and figure out
how could we get that onto the first
page
or it could be things like how do we
present that information you know for
some queries maybe you know queries like
the actual things you type into google's
search box
um for some queries uh you know that the
best possible answer might be
a five line snippet instead of a two
line snippet that's the text underneath
the heading on each result or maybe the
best result would be a picture
um and i worked on google books for four
years um working on search quality and
doing some front-end changes
later on i did the same thing on google
plus
and at the very end i worked on um
the knowledge graph so that's how do we
describe the information that we show on
google
and you obviously worked in various
places but i
want to talk about obviously the move to
facebook and so when why did you want to
move to facebook and how did it come
about was it something you'd always
wanted to work for or not
i never really
had a hunger to work at facebook um so
something that most people are not aware
of is is
if you have more than say five years of
work experience in silicon valley
a facebook recruiter will contact you
every three months
like there's enough brand damage they
have to constantly be really really
working at it like a nice yeah you've
got like nice lunches out of it nothing
but you could if you you wanted to
extract some lunches you probably could
um so they'll reach out to you and say
like oh have you ever considered working
at facebook and you know i think i was
feeling maybe a little extra punchy or a
little snarky um the day that email came
in this is like january 2019.
um because i was like the only thing i
would work on at facebook is
misinformation
and they were like oh well by the way
like we have this brand new role it's
it's civic misinformation and so it's
2019 it's like the lead up to the 2020
elections i'm like ah that's what you
know i had lived with i had i i had
someone very close in my life
um uh who i i lost in misinformation so
in 2014 i got really sick and i had to
relearn to walk
and i hired this assistant the next year
because i realized that i was so i was
still so weak like i wasn't my life
wasn't at risk anymore but like i was
still so weak that i wasn't strong
enough to like carry boxes to clean out
a storage unit that kind of thing and he
became an incredibly close friend so he
would take me walking five days a week
he would he'd like to lift weights so he
taught me how to like eat protein and
like how do you put on muscle that kind
of thing
and
in 2016
after bernie lost
the nomination right so bernie sanders
and hillary were vying to be the
democratic candidate
after he lost the nomination he just
went deeper and deeper and deeper into
these dark places on the internet over
the next six months
and by the time the 2020 election rolled
around like he and i were having like
1000 word emails back and forth on
things like does george soros run the
world economy
and i remember the day that um he
said to me he's like do you even read
your own citations these are all from
the mainstream media
and at that moment i realized like i had
just completely lost him
right like if we can't even agree on the
grounds that we can try to come to
consensus
like
there's there's no place like there's no
place for communication
and um and so when the the recruiter was
like oh you could work on civic
misinformation it was a super
interesting idea to me because
you know
losing him
to you know the depths of the internet
was really really painful for me
and i never wanted anyone to feel that
pain
um so yeah so so you join facebook on
the misinformation brief
and uh so in that role uh what what is
your job on a day-to-day basis i thought
i was joining facebook to work on
misinformation in the united states
right so it's 2019 civic misinformation
clearly this is improv for the 2020
elections
i don't know how this no one ever
explained this to me before i joined but
i actually was working on misinformation
anywhere there wasn't third-party
fact-checking
and
misinformation in the united states is
eroding our information environment it's
polarizing society
it's hurting
it's hurting a lot of different
dimensions
but in places like african countries in
southeast asia
misinformation is killing people
and what was really really shocking to
me um even in the future first few weeks
i was there was i thought i was a
relatively well-read person and i had no
idea this was going on
and
i think this is one of those things
that's really important for us globally
to talk about which is
these tech companies are huge and
they're honed in northern california and
the people who are building these
products often lack international
context
and the fact that facebook went into
some of the most fragile places on earth
and bought the right to be the internet
so they went in there and said hey if
you use facebook your data is free
if you use anything else you have to pay
for yourself
and enough people in those places
converged onto facebook as the internet
because like think about like even if a
fraction of your property of your
internet users use facebook as the
internet
there's a convergence thing that happens
where even people who pay for their data
things still end up on facebook as the
network effects
and so today there's like a billion or
two billion people for whom facebook
equals the internet and i was like uh
looking up some stuff last night and
there are a surprisingly high number of
countries in the world where the
fraction of people in that country that
say i use the internet
is smaller than the fraction of people
who say i use the i use facebook
so in so when you're looking at you come
into your role and you're looking at
what does what people in these countries
should be seeing on facebook
is is this is this a
fake news is it people kind of putting
out lies is it is the fact that it's
not really is it based on articles on
john's website was it something else
[Music]
so one of the bigger is that um i'm
always always always pushing for is
around transparency and one of the
reasons why i'm always like we need to
get access to the data which is the top
then we need to fix the online safety
bill
the reason we need researchers to have
access to the data
is
right now when when if you or i were to
talk about what is facebook or what do
people see on facebook
the closest thing we get to be able to
have evidence of like what is the
gestalt
what is viewed on facebook is something
called the most viewed content report
and then most of your content report is
so misleading it is almost like a work
of art right because like you hear most
viewed content reports you're like oh
this must be the most food content on
facebook
it only shows you the top 20 posts each
quarter only for the united states and
only for english
right that is not that's a tiny tiny
sliver of all the users in the world
only about nine percent of users speak
english
um
i have seen the most viewed content in
the tier one at-risk countries so at
facebook there's this tiering system
where they say what are the places in
the world most likely to have social
media facilitated violence
right so we've had two genocides
globally so far they were they were uh
greatly worsened by social media myanmar
where two hundred thousand people died
and ethiopia which is still unfolding
tier one at-risk countries are the ones
most likely to follow in that path
and
every two weeks the social cohesion team
used to do a thing called the virality
review
and the social cohesion team is the team
responsible for preventing genocides
because ethnic violence happens when
social cohesion breaks down like it's
very orwellian so this team used to do
this thing every two weeks where they
would bring in specialists who would
translate for us the top ten posts in
each country in the tier one so this is
like maybe
10 10 countries 12 countries
and every single post in the most food
content report was horrible
you know it was allegations that your
opponent abuses children it would be
gory scenes of violence that they claim
is happening in the next village over
but really be from seven years ago and
like six countries away
um
it would it
it really really highlighted what
happens when
you have places where facebook is the
internet
combined with algorithms that give the
most reach
the most distribution to the most
extreme ideas
combined with languages that facebook
has chosen not to support for safety
systems and when those three things all
come together
you get information environments where
people can't leave
people can't consent whether or not to
use it
and the thing that is getting blasted
out of these societies is violence
and in your role uh your misinformation
i think most people think well you're in
a role where you're helping to come
combat that
was that your experience
um
almost immediately the thing i faced was
um there was a real gap
because at facebook um
things are not meaningful unless they
can be measured
but literally the thing that we had been
told to focus on was misinformation
where there is no third party fact
tracking
so so clearly we need to work on this
because there's not third-party
fact-checking in most of the world
those places of violence didn't have
third-party fact tracking and
third-party fact-checking what if you
wish uk america would be oh so um they
literally hire journalists often from
name brand publications
um because there'll be programs embedded
at those those newspapers um i can't
name them all throughout my head
um and those people will get access to a
secret tool that only journalists get to
see that lets you see the most popular
stories on facebook and the ones that
are rising the fastest and they will
write up these little stories and do
research to explain why these things are
not true
so at facebook um
we were in this weird cache22 which is
we're supposed to work on on
misinformation in some of the most
vulnerable places in the world
but nothing at facebook is
misinformation until a third party has
set its misinformation
so how do you measure success
if you're not allowed to actually um you
have no no no ruler
and so um we worked on that for about
three months and then we were pulled off
it
to work on um
targeted misinformation that was being
sent to people like police officers in
the united states so we literally like
basically they gave up on misinformation
in places that didn't have third party
fact checkers despite the consequences
and put us back on the united states
after three months
and how did that make you feel uh it it
was my first taste of um how chaotic
things are inside of facebook
like we look at it and we say oh this is
back then it was a trillion dollar
company now it's a 500 billion dollar
company um you know we look at a
trillion dollar company and say that is
that is the pinnacle of excellence and
if people could see inside the company
they would see um
uh how remarkable it is that they've
gone as far as they have
now as i mentioned the introduction you
are a whistleblower so at what point
then you're obviously becoming very
uncomfortable with the things you're
seeing you've been moved off of this
um
and i've i would presume from what
you're saying that when you moved off
were you frustrated to be moved off well
i i that that that wasn't why i came
forward my decision to come forward
happened a full year later so and and in
some ways we got escalated onto
you know in some ways just as scary a
thing right like when misinformation is
targeted people like police like we
don't want the people carrying guns or
in the united states the police carry
guns you don't have people carrying guns
living with a different reality than
what is our shared reality um uh so i
didn't feel bad when we got moved on to
it it's just it was an example of
how dynamic things are on facebook um
the moment that i realized facebook
needed help right that it wasn't going
to be able to solve these problems alone
like i needed help to solve these
problems together
was um about a month a little less than
a month after the us 2020 election
uh
facebook announced we're dissolving our
civic integrity team
so this is the parent team that i was
part of so i worked on civic
misinformation
under civic integrity
and a little less than a month
afterwards uh they came out and said you
know your work is so important that
we're going to integrate you into all
these other places in the company
and at facebook that's not how reorgs
work right like your team either eats
other teams or your team is eaten by
other teams um
and i don't think i was the only one
that felt that way because the team that
i got moved on to
every single product manager on the team
quit in the same six-week span about six
weeks later not six weeks six months
later um so i i wasn't the only one that
left about the same time
um but the
the reason why i was like oh my goodness
like this is a problem
was
facebook's bar for success
was that there wasn't riots for 20 for
the us 2020 election
right we still were facing genocide
problems we still were facing the
algorithms giving the most reach the
most extreme ideas
but facebook was like oh like we passed
this crisis point we don't we don't need
these folks anymore and because they
dissolved civic integrity there was no
one around to form the war room to turn
the safety systems back on before
january 6th
and at 5 pm on eastern time on january
6th the whole list of safety features so
this is not this is not censorship this
is things like how much should you
amplify live video
right like facebook um regularly has a
problem with people committing suicide
on live video or killing other people on
live video like christ church in new
zealand was filmed on live video
broadcast on live video um you know
the kinds of safety things that were off
at 5 00 pm on january 6th
were were things like should you amplify
video live video 850 times
like more than it would have earned
otherwise probably not if you can't
control it
but because they got rid of civic
integrity no one was there to actually
you know pull you know
raise the red flag and say we need to
act
so when is that when you that was an
insight yeah
and um it took me a while to think
through like how to do it
and um so i'm working on counter
espionage so i was thinking
very carefully as a data scientist like
how would i
look for myself if i were like trying to
find someone who was doing this and so
it took me a long time to figure out a
plan that i felt confident
and were you able to seek advice from
anyone or not because what you're
working on is so confidential you're
quite it's actually quite like almost a
solo decision um
i had had i had had a bunch of time
during 2020 to talk to my parents
because i lived with my parents jenkovic
about um on
the things that i was seeing at work and
to talk through like what might i do and
so by the time i decided to act i'd had
lots of time to become okay with the
idea of acting so the only people i
talked to about in great depth were my
parents um and
i tried to reach out to
um
and
i'm trying to decide whether or not to
name and shame them
i reached out to a large tech advocacy
group which will remain nameless to
protect the guilty
and and told them uh
very early on so um back during the iowa
caucuses i i tried to talk to them about
like what i was seeing
and um
and they
because because back then the
conversation wasn't about how do we fix
the algorithms how do we look at the
product choices that facebook has made
that have caused the most extreme
content to get the most reach because
the only frame of reference at that
point was the frame of reference that
facebook gave
you know they said the only things we
can do to keep people safe are
censorship
that tech advocacy group was not willing
to help me at that time because they're
like well even if the public knew about
these things all they would do is censor
them
and um and so i i
i did have to do it on my own
so you make the decision uh you do it
and then what happens is there a point
where i imagine if it's you're in coba
are you working from home at this time
so it's not like you leave the office
for the for the last time yeah
uh what starts to happen after you uh
you know share that information
on the
so things things stayed very quiet for
quite a long time so it was only
right in the lead-up to
the
uh first article being published at the
wall street journal that my lawyers
started talking to me about like you
know do you want to be publicly like
like you should think really hard about
coming out publicly and you stopped
working for facebook yes yes i stopped
running for facebook back in may yeah
and um and our first article came out in
september and at that point um what do
you find uh the public reaction to be
were you ready for the scrutiny that
comes with it oh yeah
um i've had a it's so funny like um i've
been incredibly lucky
like i know how hard it's been for
um
like uh for snowden or for reality
winner or like chelsea manning like i
know i know how hard it's been for
people who have who have whistleblown on
the federal government
um there is not that level of
allegiance or goodwill towards facebook
and um i think that's why um like i
don't even get sent mean messages on my
dms
like i always say like i leave my dms
open like if you want to be mean to me
you can i do respond but i usually ask
you could you tell me more um
but people i think it's i i've had a a
very
a very fortunate emergence into the
public light because people have been
very supportive
um now
since obviously you um blew the whistle
on facebook they faced lots of scrutiny
um and i think lots of negative
publicity um but i think just for the
endless point kind of moving to the
present day i wondered i mean
first do you think facebook have learned
any lessons yet and then i want to ask
you about the online safety film
so we have seen some changes in facebook
already even without mandated changes so
the digital services act just passed in
europe
and there are many changes that are
going to be coming down the pipeline as
a result of that but even before being
forced to do things like transparency um
facebook has
launched some things that show that they
they have listened to at least some of
the criticisms so i'll give an example
uh
at any point in the last 10 years they
could have released parental controls on
instagram at any point right people have
been asking for parental controls
forever
and these are things like saying can you
assign a a time allowance to your kids
because the reality is the kids that are
most harmed by social media are the ones
that uh have um a negative relationship
with it and then end up doom
doomscrolling at 2am
3am right where their anxiety pulls them
to engage more but at the same time the
content is making them more anxious
um time budgets are important for for
kid safety
um they didn't launch those until like
two months ago like they weren't really
parental controls till then
um or facebook has made some efforts to
um try to support more languages for its
safety systems like they announced in
december that they were re-architecting
how they did those so they could try to
cover more languages
um
online safety bill currently going
through parliament i've recently
actually had a dean doris on this
podcast the culture secretary who's
leading the legislation um what do you
make of it in terms of i suppose
fairly briefly for our listeners because
obviously it's a very ex wide bill but i
just wondered um what you think is is
good that it's doing and then where you
think it actually is potentially lacking
um i think one of the places where uh
you know the uk is really establishing a
reputation around is is it it is very
thoughtful about the rights of children
and like safety by design and and
making sure that that kid more kids are
safer at least online because the
reality is the internet was not designed
for children and right now the people
playing the highest costs at least in
our societies for um
social media are our children
um
some of the places where it's a little
weaker are things like there's a large
focus on content versus on
focusing as much on systems so the
digital services act out of europe
focuses more on you know making sure
there's transparency from day one
so that means uh academics researchers
the regular gain access to data from the
start
the online safety bill says uh you know
we're going to do a two-year period
offcom is going to do a two-year period
where they're going to ask the question
should we have access to data
we've known for 10 years we need access
to data like we we would never trust an
oil company like let's imagine some kids
were sick downwind from an oil derrick
we would never turn to that oil company
and be like why do you think why do you
think these kids are sick and if they're
like have you seen the clouds in the sky
have you talked to a meteorologist yet
maybe it's maybe it's the clouds no no
we would send an environmental scientist
out there who would test the air they
would test the soil they would test the
water and they'd come back and be like
no like the oil derrick is like burning
off the stuff and there's a byproduct in
it like we when
we wouldn't ask the person committing
the harm to let us know what the
solutions are we would ask our own
questions and we would do our own
research and until we have access to
data
we cannot act independently so
the online safety bill has to move from
saying
should we have access to data to saying
how will we have access to data and
instead of it taking two years to start
giving access it should take three
months because the online the digital
service act is going to have data on day
one
starting in january is the data uh
almost uh looking at um how things are
targeted and in that sense that would be
one thing yeah right so it's a huge it's
a it's it's
it's it's things like what content gets
the most promotion right uh where are
the biases where the biases and the
censorship systems right now we have no
idea how these things work but
facebook's own documents say things like
75 percent of counterterrorism content
in some languages is getting labeled as
terrorism content and taken down
we need transparency to see how these
systems work another place where i think
the bill could be stronger is right now
it's allowing the um uh
i think it's like this the secretary is
it's allowing a minister an elected
minister to say what content should be
taken down instead of having an
independent having offcom do it
offcom is an independent regulator we
don't want to have an elected official
who might have their thumb on the scale
deciding what can and can't be said we
want the independent regulator to have
that role
yeah you mentioned that and i think one
of the criticisms that has been aired in
the spectator but also in parliament is
concerns over illegal but harmful and
how that can be
interpreted how it could move and
whether actually it could be a threat to
free speech in the sense that
you could say if you argue that
something could be harmful but it's not
actually illegal you can start to see
how um
you know
menedine doris was on the um
she was saying as to your point well
actually you know some twitter pylons
would be okay so a twitter pilot about
her would be okay and but a twitter
pilot in purpose racism would not be
okay but i think lots of people think
well in terms of the
legal harmful side you can bring more in
i wonder what do you think about that
i think there's uh
when we look at you know we said before
about the greatest harms to like say
kids a lot of the stuff that is harming
kids is totally legal content right um
one of the things that facebook's own
documents say is you know we like to
think that facebook is a mirror like
when you pull people people say oh
facebook's just showing me what what
what's representative
um in reality facebook is an amplifier
right you can take a brand new instagram
account with no friends no interests and
search for something like healthy eating
and just click on the content they give
you you know follow the hashtag
suggested and get taken to anor pro
anorexia content within two weeks
that kind of thing an algorithm that
pushes kids actively from just an
innocuous thing like healthy recipes to
pro anorexia and self-harm content
because both those things are what
facebook found
we need to make sure there's some space
in there where we can still make sure
that those things get captured and so i
think transparency is a good complement
where it's one of these things where
right now we don't know what content
they take down or leave up
we should have an ability to see what's
going on and then we can put pressure
and demo democratic accountability on
the system
yeah because i think one of the concerns
is the idea that actually you have a
situation where in a way tech companies
overly censor
because they're incentivized so as to
avoid being in trouble and take lots of
things down so if you're airing just her
on the side of caution um do you think i
mean
that's probably a bad thing part of why
i like the only thing i've been
recommending is around focusing on
systems over content so i'll give you an
example um if you divide all the content
available on facebook into content you
consented to so that's things like your
friends and family pages you actually
followed groups you actually joined
versus something like your friend
commented on something now it's inserted
in your feed
if you just give people more content
they consented to unless that they
didn't consent to
for free you get less hate speech less
violence less less nudity so
rules that say you must take down every
piece of x
i worry that you can have effects like
what you talk about if you instead say
things like you need to show me and this
is part of how the digital services act
works it says you need to tell me what
the risks are and you need to walk me
through how you're going to reduce those
risks and you need to give me data that
should show me you're making progress
that's a very different thing than
saying every last thing that is x needs
to be taken down
now two final questions for me um the
first was we've been talking about
facebook largely but i just wondered
what you make in terms of on twitter at
the moment obviously elon musk is in the
process of potentially buying it and i
think it's yet to get to go through at
the time of recording
um and lots of people saying well that's
a threat to online safety he obviously
is saying he's a freedom of speech
champion um from your side he's also
talked about publishing you know the
algorithm
from your side what do what do you make
of it in terms of that online safety
debate so i'm i'm i i get asked this
question multiple times a day yes sorry
for not being more crazy
it's totally okay i think it's a really
important question for us to talk about
um uh you know i sometimes get a little
bit of flack for saying that i'm
cautiously optimistic about it
um but i'm i'm not i'm not alone right
like um
did you see the social dilemma
so the social dilemma is the most
popular documentary that's ever been on
netflix
it's about the dangers of the algorithms
and about social media
um the lack of accountability
um and uh the director of it jeff
orlanski and i were on a panel together
right when elon announced he was doing
this
and uh we got asked that question and
both of us agreed
there's certain opportunities that come
with taking a system like that private
so a lot of the stuff that i recommend
or like i advocate for things like
saying should you have to click on a
link to re-shirt
if you require someone to click on a
link you get 10 or 15 less
misinformation but it's also gonna cost
you like point one percent of profit you
know it's not free
twitter has decided to do this in the
past
facebook hasn't
um it doesn't censor anyone right all
content is treated equally but you get
much less misinformation
going private opens up a large tool
chest of interventions like that that
are about the design of the system's
design of the algorithms
and the fact that he's come and you can
do it because you're not having to
report your profit every single quarter
doing those changes i think makes your
company more long-term successful
because it's a more pleasant place to be
um but it's going to give you slight
losses in the short term
i think the the reason why i'm
optimistic about this is elon musk has
shown for years that he's willing to ask
hard questions and accept hard answers
like you you can't have a rocket blow up
and get back on your feet and launch the
next one successfully unless you're
willing to like really look hard at
things
and um
and i think that really sets them apart
from mark like mark zuckerberg the
secondary thing is the first two things
he said he wanted to do the first was he
said i want to publish the algorithms we
all deserve to see what's in there and
the second thing he said was i'm going
to take all the robots off twitter so
for for those who aren't aware there are
little programs that pretend to be human
beings on twitter and they are and
they're on basically every other
consumer side as well and they're
literally the most dangerous thing about
social media because the people who are
weaponizing social media people like
russia china iran
they extensively use these automated
humans these fake humans to amplify out
the messages that are useful to them
and there are lots and lots of tools for
taking down these accounts but when you
have a public company
and you'll if you'll notice the reason
why the deal hasn't gone through yet is
elon said hey
it looks awfully suspicious that you've
said every quarter for a number of years
that five percent of your users are bots
i think you don't know how many of your
users are real
um and and that's that's true and it's
because
uh in
every single time you take a robot off
twitter
you have one less user right the value
of your company went down a little bit
and for those who don't watch the price
of tech companies really carefully if
you lose one percent of what users
sometimes your stock falls 10 percent
you can solve fifteen percent and so
there's a real cost to doing the right
thing for a public company but the fact
that elon said let's take the bots off
shows he's talking to people who know
something about what's going on
so and the [ __ ] the final question we
ask everyone is um what is the worst
advice you've ever been given
um so
the boomers really always said like you
need to buy a house you need to buy a
house you need to buy a house the single
worst thing i ever did in my life was i
bought a house
and because i bought a house
when i bought a house so i bought it at
a very
very wise time economically like i
bought it in 2010 like at the very
bottom of the market
but because i renovated a house in my
20s it meant that when i got
hospitalized i had almost no money like
i had spent all the savings i had
gone from working in tech in my 20s
on renovating this house right because i
bought a foreclosed in a condemned house
because it was all i could afford in
california
and i
because of that i went back to work
after i was sick
way too soon like i went back to work
two weeks after i stopped walking with a
cane
and i was cause i was out of money
and um and so now i always tell people i
know you want to buy a house i know you
really want to i know it feels crazy
watching the price of houses get higher
and higher and higher but like
just don't buy a house before you're 30.
just don't just wait i know you want it
i know you want to build stability
just just build up the war chest higher
um and
because i i really wish i had had more
flexibility during that time period
thank you francis